voi sapete chi è lui è un ornitorinco un
animale che vive in australia un animale
strano e per questa ragione molto
probabilmente ha sempre attirato la mia
attenzione vi saluta guardatelo ha il
becco come quello di una papera poi alle
zampe palmate esattamente come quelle di
una papera però non ne ha due ne ha
quattro alla pelliccia che assieme a
quella di un visione o forse è più
probabile come quella di una nutria ed
ha la coda come quella di un castoro
ma la cosa straordinaria è che essi un
mammifero ma depone le uova depone le
uova marta bravo mammifero allatta i
cuccioli che animale è è semi acquatico
quindi vive sia nell'acqua che sulla
terra ed è l'unico esemplare della sua
famiglia del suo genere non apparenti il
che forse è un po solo poverino
descritto così sembra un nerd uno
sfigato
invece se andiamo a vedere i testi
miliari dell'educazione della nostra
educazione alla natura per esempio il
manuale delle giovani marmotte
lui è un animale che ha delle qualità
uniche ha il senso di elettro locazione
che pochi animali hanno cioè cattura le
prede individuandone l'energia è un
nuotatore olimpionico e nuota senza
usare la vista ma usando gli altri sensi
poi può nuotare per ora in acque gelide
e la sua temperatura corporea non varia
di un grado quindi per me può essere
tranquillamente la controfigura di keanu
reeves in matrix un vero figo
eppure di lui non si sono dette delle
cose esaltanti la leggenda australiana
narra che nacque dall'incrocio di
un'anatra con il topo il topo la rapì si
approfittò di lei e nacque lui non
proprio un buon inizio
i primi coloni britannici che lo
individuarono intercettarono lo uccisero
ovviamente lo scuoiare portarono in
patria la pelle intera e lo fecero
esaminare dagli studiosi gli studiosi
britannici dissero che un animale così
non poteva assolutamente esistere
era senza dubbio un falso confezionato
ad arte da un imbalsamatore asiatico in
filosofia è la metafora di tutto ciò che
complica le classificazioni quindi non è
classificabile
di conseguenza non è comprensibile di
conseguenza non è un esempio
puntualmente finisce tra le specie
vulnerabili che è la lista che precede
immediatamente la lista rossa delle
specie in via di estinzione a tutti gli
effetti però ad oggi non è ancora finito
lì
io mi sono sempre sentita ornitorinco
non tanto per il mio fisico o tutti i
pezzi appartenenti ad una stessa specie
sembra ma perché mi sono sempre sentita
diversa rispetto all'ambiente che mi
circondava vivevo a selva del montello
un piccolissimo paesino in provincia di
treviso ma con la mia testa
io ero a seattle negli stati uniti
perché da lì veniva la mia prozia oliva
che dopo una vita vissuta a seattle
rientrò in patria proprio quando nacqui
zia oliva era la mia baby sitter e mi
parlava in inglese in un paese e selva
del montello dove ancora oggi la lingua
ufficiale è il dialetto
se tu parli italiano sei già strano da
piccola poi dicevo di voler fare il
falegname una femmina non puoi sognare
di fare l'infermiera come tuam no
il falegname da sempre sono una gran
chiacchierona in una famiglia di persone
taciturne a casa mia si possono passare
ore senza spiaccicare parola io ero
diversa mi sentivo in un modo e capivo
di essere percepita in un altro mi
sentivo a posto tutto sono morto ma
capivo di essere percepita strana e
dietro di me un coro di pareri e frasi
lapidarie bambina socievole in un'area
geografica di orsi chiacchierona lingua
lunga bambina con un attitudine creativa
e poi voglio andare a fare il liceo
artistico di arte non si vive
vado all'università questa scelgo segue
orientali giapponese e poi decido di
mandare curricula prima di finire gli
studi e mi assume un'azienda una
multinazionale americana subito chissà
quando mai ti assumeranno subito senza
una laurea non vai da nessuna parte un
buon lavoro non lo troverai mai dopo
dieci anni di quel buon lavoro nella
multinazionale americana decidono che è
ora di cambiare qualcosa
capisco che non solo più a posto con me
stessa e prendo la decisione di
licenziarmi senza un piano b quindi mi
licenzio da un contratto a tempo
indeterminato senza un piano b ma sei
pazza non lo sai che fuori c'è la crisi
dove vivi tu in quel periodo che è stato
il periodo sabbatico che fa figo direi
sabbatico sono tornata alla bambina
falegname o avviato una piccola attività
un laboratorio di compra vendita di
mobili usati non antichi usati becchi li
compravo li colora voli restaura voli
rivendevo indovinate
figurati cosa pensi di fare vabbè questi
qua in parte avevano ragione la everest
della burocrazia italiana non aiuta
tantissimo un piccolo laboratorio
vabbè ho messo un attimo da parte la
civetta sul comò xvi che aveva così
emiri programma ritorno a fare quello
che ho fatto per dieci anni e dove
comunque avevo lasciato il mio cuore ma
ci ritorno da libero professionista
libera professionista
ah beh cosa pensate il supporto chiti
ripiglia dopo che hai fatto il falegname
nel mezzo non ce la fa
hai mai questa frase me la ricordo
benissimo pronunciata da un consulente
aziendale che avevo interpellato che ne
dici se non ce la farai mai
sono otto anni che faccio quel lavoro da
libero professionista felice
eccomi qua puntualmente durante il
percorso mi fermavo mi guardavo dentro e
mi vedevo diversa mi percepivo un essere
diverso ero l'ornitorinco ho sempre
fatto quello che avevo in mente sono
sempre arrivata dove volevo arrivare e
vi assicuro che ho visto tante magie
accadere da dove sono partite ho sempre
sognato tanto io dico di me che potrei
fare la donna o tizio e di sogni e mi
sono sempre attrezzata per realizzarli
quei sogni lo sappiamo quando ci
incamminiamo prendiamo il sogno e lo
portiamo a terra e cerchiamo di
realizzarlo
incontriamo un sacco di ostacoli lo
sappiamo tutti
il primo è quel coro lì io però a un
certo punto dopo tanto ho capito che il
mio primo ostacolo non erano i
condizionamenti giudizi pensieri la voce
degli altri e non era nemmeno la mia
voce interiore condizionata da quelli
era un altro il mio problema
un ostacolo molto grande io avevo il
bisogno assoluto di far convivere i due
anime molto diverse opposte quella
creativa artistica e quella molto
razionale due anime molto belle
molto forti con gli stessi diritti di
esistere avanzavo tirata da una tirata
dall'altra cercando di gratificare 1 e
cercando di gratificare con l'altra
quindi avanzavo con il freno a mano
tirato
ero un essere potenziale esplosivo ma
ostacolato quelle contraddizioni interne
e quelle tensioni le sentiamo tutti e
tutti in qualche modo e per qualche cosa
ci sentiamo diverse
però a una diversità che è tutto sommato
banale
il punto non è la diversità in se e come
ci stiamo dentro quella diversità
io ho sofferto tanto ma ho fatto lo
stesso tirò fuori e sogno dal cassetto
faccio pianifico faccio cado mi rialzo
ha giusto il tiro faccio mi tappo le
orecchie perché io credo che
l'ornitorinco si tappi le orecchie per
non estinguersi faccio arrivo al
risultato
faccio e mentre arrivo il risultato sto
già sempre facendo un'altra cosa perché
io ho capito che non è il risultato che
mi fa felice
è il percorso che mi fa arrivare agli
enel fare che io sono felice ed è lì che
voglio stare per questa ragione io dico
che per me il fare è l'attivatore di
felicità faccio sempre anche quando mi
ritrovo nel buio nel tunnel e quel
famoso tunnel dove vedi la lucina
piccola piccola poi si ingrandisce e tu
ti ritrovi asfaltato perché non era la
lucina erano i fari del tir mi rialzo un
po appiattita e li medico questa frase
marianna guardati i piedi questo è il
momento di guardarti piedi ed andare
avanti
questa frase è la frase che più mi sono
ripetuto nella mia vita ed è una frase
che è finita nel manuale di fornitori
anno
eccolo qua adesso lo prendo e vi voglio
leggere delle cose il manuale di
ornitorinco è una raccolta di frasi ad
effetto come quella lì di sprone di
stimolo regole istruzioni trucchi
escamotage ordini che mi do è la mia
guida del fare un po come il manuale
delle
giovani marmotte infatti qui dentro è la
prima pagina c'è una frase una dedica
che io ho fatto a me stessa che è il
mantra di ornitorinchi do io chi sono
nella vita non lascio decidere agli
altri che detta dai miei genitori suona
così as a star tanto con la pensa ad all
anca fatta
tradotto dal dialetto di selva del
montello lascia stare tanto non ha
nemmeno finito il pensiero che la sta
già facendo è diviso in capitoli molto
lunghi e ho il piacere di o la voglia il
piacere di condividere con voi due punti
per capitolo i due punti che per me sono
stati più illuminanti nel mio fare il
capitolo del do fiducia dà fiducia a me
stessa e alle mie intuizioni do fiducia
ai miei amici ai miei alleati ai miei
cheerleader quelli con i pon pon che
saltano danzano e tifano sempre per me
perché mi vogliono bene
il capitolo del rispetto rispetto ai
miei valori e mi monitorò con costanza
su questo rispetto il tempo fisiologico
di cose e persone
io di mio sono una persona impaziente
tutto subito non funziona lo sappiamo
il capitolo del mi permetto mi permetto
i momenti di sconforto
tanto lo so il supero mi permetto la
parte giocosa in tutto quello che faccio
io mi devo divertire il capitolo del mi
proteggo da tutti gli accademici in ogni
cosa che fai c'è sempre qualcuno con un
titolo importante più importante del tuo
che ti sa dire come devi fare quello che
stai facendo probabilmente anche ragione
facciamo che facciamo lo stesso e poi
casomai li aggiustiamo il tiro
mi proteggo nella quotidianità dai
deliri degli altri questa è l'epoca del
tutto subito di tutti tranne per me non
ho capito se non vale per me non voglio
neanche per gli altri
il capitolo dei non non cerco l'ancora
dell'essere pronta non lo sarò mai
non cado nella trappola della vittima
carnefice del perfezionismo non vado
avanti
se dopo aver sentito il cuore e
analizzato con la testa
la mia pancia dice no perché lei ha
sempre ragione
il capitolo della accolgo accolgono
errore tanto so che è funzionale al
processo evolutivo e accolgo la crisi
perché nel momento di crisi che io
riesco a conoscere bene me stessa a
conoscermi meglio e riesco ad aggiustare
il tiro del fare con quel sistema ali
del me lo metto in testa faccio e con il
manuale in mano
recentemente ho scritto un libro con un
co autore illustre perché sennò chi se
lo filava il libro di maiale comunque
non è stato semplice il primo ostacolo
il coro che poi in realtà era più la mia
voce interiore
tu non sei una scrittrice vero però
volevo farlo lo stesso perché sapevo
dentro di me che avrebbe fatto del bene
a qualcuno
poi c'era la voce reale dell'editore noi
libri così non li facciamo
vi ricordate i miei genitori a star ok
libro pubblicato è fatto un fare
terribile cadute to negli infiniti buio
assoluto pubblicato primo risultato
oggettivo e per rispondere all'editore
dopo sole tre settimane è andato in
ristampa
ma il risultato vero per me è stato un
altro io ho iniziato a ricevere messaggi
di sconosciuti non i miei amici che mi
vogliono bene si sono prodigati
a dirmi brava quanto siamo fieri di te
no da sconosciuti mi scusi se la
disturbo la volevo ringraziare aperto
grazie per aver scritto queste cose
grazie per aver raccontato queste aver
raccontato quest'altra quei grazie sono
stati un'iniezione di fiducia totale e
di felicità estremo ma soprattutto mi
hanno fatto capire che il fare non è
solo l'attivatore di felicità per me
stessa è l'attivatore di felicità anche
per gli altri
attraverso di me ed è questa la cosa
meravigliosa
io conclude o dicendo questo
l'ornitorinco è strano sì
sentiamoci bene dell'essere ornitorinco
vogliamoci bene
accettiamo ogni pezzo di noi conosciamo
ci amiamo c è diamoci veramente da fare
per essere chi vogliamo essere nella
vita
noi lasciamo stare agli altri